So how'd all the logging code go?
>> It went great, I'm actually having
a launch party for version three soon.
Let me show you all the screens and
features we made from the wireframes.
We're now supporting email login and
Google login.
We also created a pretty
cool reset password flow
where users are sent their
passwords via email and
therefore verifying that they actually
own the email that they've given us.
But we worked on more than just
login in this version of the app.
We used the login data to change
what the app actually looks like.
The app now controls what the user sees
based on who they are logged in as.
Also, we can keep track of who
buys what items and allow for
users to signal that they're
actively shopping on a list.
>> Yeah, and now we're halfway
through our projected final launch.
Anyways, we're having a little 0.3
launch party, you should come.
>> I'll see what I can do.